[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
laurent alexandre pour son nouveau livre
jouissez jeunesse dans lequel il nous
exhorte à ne pas avoir peur de la fin du
monde
nicolas michaud qui sort un nouvel album
amour colère et le meilleur clip de
l'année en tout cas le plus
représentatif de notre époque vous allez
voir et stéphane rose l'auteur d'en
finir avec le couple va essayer de nous
convaincre que si nous vivons en couple
ce n'est pas parce que nous avons avons
envie ou que nous aimons cela mais que
c'est uniquement par tradition parce que
c'est comme ça et pas autrement
mais commençons tout de suite par le
rituel du début d'émission qu'est ce qui
caractérise ce début de xxième siècle à
part les masques évidemment nous inviter
à un ponton images voici la vôtre
stéphane rose
de quoi s'agit-il
une bagarre générale parce que j'ai
l'impression que y'a pus trop de socle
de valeurs communes comme dans la
société que j'ai toujours connu où le
débat et la confrontation existait mais
où on arrivait à former une société à
peu près cohérente
aujourd'hui tout le monde se frite avec
tout le monde alors on choisit une
communauté on se victimise ont un peu et
chacun pour sa gueule donc les antilles
masque contre les pros masquer les laïcs
contre les croyants qui s'allie aux
antilles charlie contre les pros charlie
les féministes abolo contre les pro sexe
les indigéniste à poils durs contre les
suprématistes à poil ras
j'en passe un vous voyez à peu près
l'idée et pendant ce temps là bas je
pense que le pouvoir
mange des pop corn en nous regardant ce
nous friter voilà fait et on va voir
aussi les pessimistes contre les
optimistes avec laurent alexandre dans
un instant mais d'abord l'image choisie
par nicolas michaud ah ben voilà la
russie là aussi ça se fritent nicolas
oui en effet ça me semble assez bien
résumé ce qui s'est passé durant les six
derniers mois il ne suffit pas de ne
suffit pas de d'applaudir à 20h et de
dire que l'on va changer etc
on voit bien que quelques mois plus tard
le naturel revient au galop et que le
que les chantres du néolibéralisme
ne ne peuvent pas ne peuvent pas
s'empêcher de reconsidérer l'hôpital
public et des travailleurs comme des
comme des chargés comme des coûts et
voilà sont des infirmières
c'est vite passé la parenthèse est vite
passé ce sont des infirmières un convoi
sur cette image
oui tout à fait et laurent alexandre son
image elle lui mais ce sont des
téléphones portables je crois que c'est
le record depuis que je fais cette
émission le nombre de téléphones
portables qu'on a mis sa et les masques
si j'avais laissé les gens mettre des
masques
alors là on aurait mis des masques tous
les jours mais le téléphone portable a
beaucoup de succès aussi alors pourquoi
avez vous choisi vous le rôle alexandre
parce que c'est la technologie qui s'est
imposé le plus vite de l'histoire de
l'humanité on a près de 5 milliards de
téléphones portables sous forme de
smartphone sur terre en 12 années
d'existence
donc c'est un finalement le miroir de
l'accélération technologique de ce début
de xxième siècle oui il faut se souvenir
que le téléphone par exemple a mis très
très longtemps pour se répandre la
dernière fois quand la france a été
entièrement raccordé au téléphone s'est
soulevé les giscard d'estaing par
exemple lors que le téléphone existait
depuis le 19e siècle au bout de vos
bouts de 100 tonnes téléphone quand
giscard et arrivent au pouvoir en 1974
il n'y avait que 7 millions de personnes
raccordées au téléphone portable
la généralisation du télé du téléphone
fixe par dont la généralisation du
téléphone fixe n'était pas du tout
réalisé au bout d'un siècle de
technologie alors qu'au bout de quelques
années de smartphones la totalité de la
population est équipée
on a vraiment une accélération dans le
rythme d'adhésion technologique et bien
commençons
[Musique]
laurent alexandre vous avez intitulé
votre nouvel essai jouissez jeunesse
alors pourquoi ce titre pour être
provocant pas du tout parce que je pense
qu'il ya un grand combat politique à
mener aujourd'hui pour empêcher les
ayatollahs verts de mettre nos enfants
sous prozac
ce qui caractérise l'idéologie verte
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle a des filles
décider de sa 10è de d'instrumentaliser
de panique et de démoraliser la jeunesse
et d'ailleurs ça marche très très bien
un sondage réalisé en australie il n'y a
pas qu'en france qu'il y a des
ayatollahs verts a montré que 27% des
gamins entre 10 et 14 ans pense que la
fin du monde écologique arrivera avant
leurs 18 ans je ne sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte un petit australien sur
quatre pense que le monde aura disparu à
cause du réchauffement climatique avant
qu'il ait sa majorité de de traumatiser
nos gamins comme ça et je trouve
criminel c'est une grave faute politique
on a le droit de faire de la politique
et d'être clivant mais on n'a pas le
droit de mettre une génération entière
sous prozac parce que c'est une bombe
qui va nous péter à la gueule
et puis de démoraliser les jeunes c'est
vraiment dégueulasse
y'a pas que les ayatollahs verts qui
nous disent que si on continue comme ça
on va dans le mur
la plupart des politiques nous disent
ils oublient de le dire quand ils
donnent des milliards à l'industrie
automobile et où l industrie
aéronautique
mais de l'autre côté il nous dise si on
continue comme ça on va dans le mur
pourquoi ne le dites vous pas vous c'est
parce que vous êtes climato sceptiques
parce que vous pensez que le
réchauffement climatique n'est pas le
népal eux en fin du mois que le lait
l'être humain n'est pas responsable du
réchauffement climatique
qu'est ce qui vous rend moins
pessimistes que les autres alors d'abord
je n'ai jamais été climato sceptiques je
suis convaincu qu'il y ait un
réchauffement climatique lié
principalement au gaz à effet de serre
en revanche un pays comme la france qui
est le plus vertueux au monde grâce au
programme nucléaire en termes
d'émissions de co2 n'a pas à être ça
disait c'est en inde en afrique en chine
aux états unis en russie qu'il faut agir
contre les gaz à effet de serre par
ailleurs la la dramatisation actuelle
par les écologistes a conduit à fermer
des centrales nucléaires comme
fessenheim et le résultat est
catastrophique pour le climat par
exemple on a au printemps fermer
fessenheim et les centrales nucléaires
et met 4 grammes de co2 par
kilowattheure produit et dans le même
temps on est en train de construire une
centrale à gaz
alors que les centrales à gaz et met 420
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure et
comme on à fermer fessenheim pour
compenser depuis la rentrée on allume en
france en ce moment des centrales à
charbon cette fois ci qui émettent 850
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure donc on
ferme
fessenheim qui produisait 4 grammes de
co2 au kilomètre heure et on émet
maintenant 850 grammes de co2 c'est à
dire 200 fois plus ah là là à la place
donc la stratégie de panique engendrée
par les écologistes traduit par une
aberration pour le climat qui est de
remplacer du nucléaire par du gaz et par
du charbon avec son à 200 fois plus
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
sont effectivement mauvais pour le
climat donc les verts en réalité parce
que ce sont des ignares en économie et d
ignares en économie de l'énergie
j'ai eu l'occasion ces derniers jours de
débattre avec des verres et de me rendre
compte à quel point ils sont nuls en
connaissance de l'énergie et du co2 pour
faire plaisir aux verts en réalité on
est en train d'aggraver le réchauffement
climatique
d'ailleurs le bilan du maquereau nisme
du fait de la fermeture de centrales
nucléaires ce sera l'aggravation du
réchauffement climatique climatique
tout ça pour fair play
faire plaisir aux ayatollahs verts je
trouve ça absolument tragique
cette politique énergétique est
suicidaire et les verts sont
irresponsables d'aggraver les gaz à
effet de serre c'est vrai que cet été le
magazine the economist a rendu hommage à
pierre messmer le premier ministre
de georges pompidou celui qui avait
choisi après la crise du pétrole le tout
nucléaire
c'était tôt à la fin de l'année 1973 et
j'économise disait que si tous les
dirigeants des pays développés à
l'époque avait imité la france il n'y
aurait pas eu de réchauffement
climatique
vous le pensez aussi à bien sûr si tous
les pays avaient fait comme la france le
problème du réchauffement climatique ne
se poserait pas et de voir aujourd'hui
qu'on va faire exploser les compteurs de
co2 en fermant les centrales nucléaires
me rend malade
mais les écologistes sont irresponsables
ce sont aujourd'hui les grands
responsables de l'aggravation du
réchauffement climatique
parce qu'en réalité il n'en a rien à
[ __ ] du co2 et du réchauffement
climatique
ils sont anti nucléaires pour des
raisons idéologiques parce que c'est
leur adn et leur objectif c'est de
fermer les centrales nucléaires même si
cela aggrave extrêmement rapidement le
réchauffement climatique je suis écoeuré
écoeuré par la stratégie énergétique
complètement cynique des écologistes
mais on voit bien en lisant votre livre
laurent alexandre que pour vous au fond
nous vivons notre âge d'or en tout cas
dans un pays comme la france ça semble
une évidence à vos yeux
technologiquement sur le plan de la
santé même financièrement on n'a jamais
été aussi riche aussi bien portants on
n'a jamais vécu aussi longtemps
dans un pays assez pacifié qui n'a
jamais été aussi peu violent donc c'est
un âge d'or mais en même temps cet âge
d'or est menacée à la fois par
l'ignorance l'ignorance scientifique
mais ligne ross historique aussi il est
menacé également par l'état de droit est
menacée et au fond on est de moins en
moins rationnelles ou plutôt de plus en
plus irrationnel et mûr pour une
dictature
c'est assez paradoxal oui oui nous
vivons un âge d'or c'est évident je me
permets de rappeler qu'avant 1888 et
l'invention de l'apa discectomie par
charles kraft à lausanne quand votre
gamin avait une appendicite aiguë on
appelait pas le médecin
on appelait le curé et le croque mort
parce que 100% des appendicites crevé on
ne savait pas traiter les appendicite
aiguë avant 1888 en 1900 encore il y
avait un petit français sur cinq qui
mouraient avant d'atteindre ces cinq ans
l'espérance de vie était à 27 ans à
paris il n'y a pas très longtemps et
greta tonnes berg devraient se rappeler
elle qui fait des leçons à la terre
entière que il y a deux trois siècles
quand il n'y avait pas de frigidaires
pas de pesticides
pas d'engrais pas de papa de semences
moderne et qui avait pas de camions pour
transporter les gras les famines était
tellement terrible dans son pays en
suède qu'on dit notaient dès qu'on dit
noté des cas important de cannibalisme
comme dans la france de louis xiv sous
louis xiv il ya eu 2 famine qui ont fait
deux millions de morts
à elles deux dans un pays qui avait 23
25 millions d'habitants donc l'âge d'or
du passé il est complètement fantasmer
en réalité le passé était épouvantable
on mourait très jeune quand on était
malade on ne pouvait pas être soigné et
à part la très haute bourgeoisie et
l'aristocratie les gens crever de faim
et de froid en permanence à parler et et
qui étaient parfois caniculaires et il y
a eu une canicule sous louis xiv qui a
fait sept cent mille morts
donc oui nous vivons un âge d'or et le
monde est beaucoup plus doux
avant mais en même temps nous avons la
remontée d'un courant irrationnelle qui
est assez désespérant on imaginait que
les lumières étaient définitivement
inscrite dans l'esprit à des français en
réalité on voit bien sûr le débat
écologique à quel point l'irrationalité
forte mais c'est un petit peu normal
notre cerveau a été produit par la
sélection darwinienne pour réfléchir
très vite en dépensant très peu
d'énergie parce que la nourriture était
jadis rare mais il n'est pas bien
adaptés pour résoudre des problèmes
compliqués en réalité notre cerveau est
parfait pour aller à la chasse au
mammouth
il est très mal adapté pour résister aux
prédictions apocalyptiques des agnettes
laser mais il est également préparer
notre cerveau à avoir peur et c'est
souvent ce qui nous a sauvés quand on
allait à la chasse au mammouth c'est
parce qu'on avait peur que on rester
vivant et qu'on pouvait faire des
enfants qui allaient avoir des enfants
aujourd'hui que on a peut-être moins de
raison d'avoir peur
on continue d'avoir peur parce que notre
cerveau est entraîné à cela et après
tout c'est peut-être ce qui nous
permettra de survivre à darwinien comme
vous ne va pas me contredire néanmoins
aujourd'hui comment ne pas avoir peur
quand on nous annonce la fonte de la
banquise la montée des eaux la
recrudescence des catastrophes
naturelles et des épidémies
la réduction de la biodiversité et or
c'est ce que nous promettent tous les
scientifiques en tout cas une grande
majorité d'entre eux depuis 25 ans
maintenant
oui bien sûr les ayatollahs verts nous
prévenons prévoit des catastrophes
permanente
mais souvenez-vous le pic des morts par
catastrophes naturelles sur terre c'est
1931 3 million et demi de morts il y en
a aujourd'hui 100 fois moins la réalité
derrière le discours qu'on nous assène
c'est que les catastrophes naturelles tu
100 fois moins de terriens chaque année
qui lie à 100 ans alors même que la
population a été multipliée par bientôt
4 donc on nous prévoit plein de
catastrophe mais la réalité c'est que la
pollution de l'air s'est effondré à
paris le smog le so2 les suit ont été
divisés par 1000 depuis 1955
les métaux lourds dans l'air le plomb
dans l'air a été divisée par mille à
paris sur les 60 dernières années on
nous explique que la pollution de l'air
est de pire en pire alors qu'elle
s'améliore d'année en année depuis
maintenant 60 ans donc oui les
ayatollahs verts ont convaincu les
français et notamment les jeunes
français que la fin du monde est là en
réalité il y a beaucoup de domaine
écologique ou la situation s'améliore
l'eau est de meilleure qualité
l'alimentation n'a jamais été aussi
saine
les intoxications alimentaires faisait
2000 morts chaque année en france en
1900 la pollution de l'air on l'a vu
s'effondre la diversité s'améliorant
france avec une augmentation très rapide
du nombre de gros mammifères le nombre
d'ours en france a été multiplié par
trois et demi en quelques années le
nombre de loups est passé de 0 loup à
550 loup ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
certains écologistes comme josé bové
réclame qu'on ne tue la totalité des
loups français parce qu'ils trouvent que
la biodiversité ne doit n'est pas si
bonne que ça et le nombre de lynx en
france est passé de zéro à plusieurs
centaines depuis 1972
donc derrière le tableau apocalyptique
on a bien sûr des problèmes écologiques
qu'il faudrait
les rationnellement mais on a une
amélioration globale de la situation
écologique qui est spectaculaire et qui
est très positive
d'ailleurs l'université de yale aux
états unis a fait un classement mondial
des pays selon leur qualité écologique
et la france est le deuxième pays le
plus écologique au monde derrière la
suisse
donc oui il y a des problèmes
écologiques que nous devons régler
rationnellement
oui les écologistes commence à nous les
gonfler à nous annoncer la fin du monde
alors que la france est un pays dont la
situation écologique s'améliore
constamment et qui était un exemple pour
le monde avec une très faible émission
de co2 et des indicateurs verts qui sont
chacun est meilleure depuis maintenant
plusieurs décennies
donc le le discours de culpabilisation
de la france le discours apocalyptique
pour faire peur à nos gamins est
indécent parce que la france est
objectivement un bon modèle écologique
en 2020 si nous sommes à un aussi bon
modèle écologique d'après vous laurent
alexandre c'est parce que au fond on a
fait confiance à la technologie on a
fait confiance au progrès et on n'a pas
décidé au contraire de revenir comme le
dit présent de la république à la lampe
à huile
ce que vous nous reprochez au fond vous
le dites c'est qu'en ce moment même
certains continuent de parier sur la
technologie et que nous nous avons cessé
de parier sur la technologie et qu'on a
tort
au fond si on écoute les verts d'après
vous on prend l'autoroute de l'histoire
à contresens
mais si on ne les écoute pas on a
l'impression qu'on fait comme donald
trump et donald trump
il est il a une grande confiance dans
l'hydroxyde chloroquine ça doit pas être
comme pas non plus deux pour cette
raison ne serait ce que pour cette
raison je suis un anti tron notamment à
cause de ses positions
climato-sceptiques moi qui suis
convaincu du réchauffement climatique et
qui est pro nucléaire pour cette raison
vous l'avez compris oui la technologie
et la richesse est nécessaire pour
devenir vert
quand on regarde sur 150 ans à l'échelle
mondiale on se rend compte que les
populations commencent à s'intéresser à
l'environnement
quand le niveau de vie par habitant à
rive entre 2000 et 5000 dollars par an
et par habitant quand on crève de faim
quand on a pas bhl de quoi nourrir ses
enfants
on s'occupe pas de l'environnement ont
foulé déchets dans la rivière
on peut lui on en a rien à [ __ ] c'est
quand on commence à être riche et qu'on
a un bon niveau de vie qu'on s'occupe de
la nature
donc oui les pays les plus riches sont
les pays qui s'occupe le plus de
l'environnement et c'est pas un accident
si la suisse qui est l'un des pays les
plus riches au monde à l'environnement
le mieux protégé
donc oui demain on va diminuer notre
empreinte énergétique notre prince
écologique grâce à la technologie on va
épurer l'eau on va épurer l'air on va
améliorer encore la biodiversité
regardez comment on est passé d'une
situation de quasi extinction des
baleines en 1955 à une situation en 2020
où il n'y a quasiment plus d'espèces de
baleine qu'ils soient menacés il ya
encore des espèces de baleines qui ont
des difficultés mais il y en a aucune
qui est au bord de l'extinction
donc il faut que l'on règle les
problèmes écologiques grâce à la prise
de conscience de la population grâce à
la technologie et sans passer par la
case prozac pour nos enfants lors
alexandre offert ce que vous dites à la
jeunesse quand vous lui dites jouissez
jeunesse cboe lui dit un le monde est
génial ne vous laissez pas déprimé tout
est à faire
tout est possible aussi oui bien sûr la
jeunesse va vivre une époque
extraordinaire au mode et us arrive
régulé au mot d uc pas si simple la
jeunesse qui arrive aux manettes
aujourd'hui va devoir savoir ce qu'on
fait
technologie aussi bouleversante que le
bébé à la carte les manipulations
génétiques les voyages spatiaux
les modifications cérébrales que l 'on
mosca commencé avec sa société n'aura
neural inc tout ça ce sont des chantiers
intimidant fantastique mais qui qui qui
vont entraîner certaines craintes et
c'est la jeunesse qui va devoir gérer
cet homo des us cet homme dieu tout
puissant avec les technologies ntic et
qui arrive et puis jeudi à la jeunesse
ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya des
chantiers technologique possiblement
intimidant qu'il faut écouter les grands
moineaux de game of thrones les
savonarole du 21e siècle
il faut jouir de ce vis de ce monde
extraordinaire et je me permettrai juste
de rappeler aux gamins qui ont 20 ans
aujourd'hui que quand moi j'avais 20 ans
1980 c'était le début de l'épidémie de
sida
et chaque fois qu on baisait on avait
peur d'attraper le sida
rien que pour ça il vaut mieux quand on
est un jeune vivre en 2020 que de vivre
en 1981 au tout début de l'épidémie de
sida qui a tué rien qu'en france des
dizaines de milliers de jeunes au début
de leur vie sexuelle
il ya il ya nicolas michaud qui vous
écouter et qui avait envie de réagir je
vous en jeu peu après nicolas oui oui
oui bah enfin réagir je sais pas je sais
pas si je suis habilité exactement
réagir chacun chacun pense ce qui vaut
mais mais là oui je suis un peu je suis
un peu étonné je suis un peu étonné que
monsieur alexandre s'adresse comme ça à
la jeunesse on ayant là ça donne un peu
l'impression qui s'est un peu mieux que
les jeunes même les enjeux qui sont qui
sont devant tôt et voilà je me retrouve
pas du tout non dans la lecture dans la
lecture que monsieur alexandre fait ça
me semble être une lecture très très
très réactionnaire gj j'ai vraiment du
mal avec l'idée que les pays riches soit
soit serait manifestement les pays les
plus les plus responsables en termes de
réchauffement climatique il me semble
justement que les pays riches comme les
états unis le canada la france fait les
pays occidentaux en général sont
beaucoup plus responsables du
réchauffement climatique les pays en
voie de développement enfin je dis ça me
semble assez assez évident j'ai
l'impression que on vient remettre en
cause ici des choses
bon voilà je suis un peu je suis un peu
étonné par le discours de monsieur
alexandre zeller
j'ai l'impression que greta tune buried
que la génération greta tune berg
absolument pas besoin des conseils de
monsieur alexandre lors alexandre vous
voyez vous comme un progressiste mais on
vous voit parfois comme un réactionnaire
ça aussi c'est paradoxal alors les
réactionnaires ce sont les écologistes
ils veulent retourner au temps d'avant
la technologie regarder en ce moment le
psychodrame autour de la 5g
je ne parle même pas du tour de france
qui est un autre sujet je me permets
monsieur michaud de vous dire que vous
n'avez pas lu mon livre je ne donne pas
de conseils à la jeunesse
je lui dis juste qu'elle a un univers
extraordinaire devant elle que nous
n'avons pas de leçons à lui donné que
nous n'avons pas de guide à lui donner
et qu'elle va devoir dans les décennies
qui viennent faire des choix
technologiques philosophique absolument
extraordinaire et mon livre n'est pas du
tout réactionnaire il n'est pas du tout
paternaliste mais comme vous ne l'avez
pas lu et d'ailleurs je vous conseille
de lire jouer c'est jeunesse vous verrez
qu'il est aux antipodes de ce que vous
imaginez j'ai vite trop de deux joué
trop les vieux cons et je ne me
permettrais pas de donner des conseils
au gamin de 20 ans aujourd'hui je me
permets juste de leur rappeler que deux
montants c'était beaucoup moins bien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un conseil
néanmoins que vous donnez à la jeunesse
selon alexandre c'est de sauver l'europe
vous dit pas ce que l'europe au fond
naples ne fait plus le choix de la
technologie elle l'a fait autrefois si
on se reporte ya un siècle l'europe et
la france était temps était en pointe
dans tous les secteurs de la technologie
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
devenir arriérés et on l'a vu pendant la
crise du comique
oui le recul technologique de l'europe
est terrible donc il faut que nous nous
réveillons et jouissez jeunesse se
termine par une phrase à la jeunesse
fait des bébés et donné leur l'amour du
futur du progrès de la liberté et de
l'europe
vous êtes vous pensez vraiment que
demain sera mieux qu'aujourd'hui
écoutez si l'un d'entre nous à l'est
dans le passé il n'y resterais pas
longtemps je vous envoie en 13 149 vous
panique huriez au bout de quelques
minutes
sous louis xiv à la première migraine
vous supplier pour avoir du doliprane
on peut multiplier les exemples avait
bien la vie en miniature ce qu alger la
vie en 1943 n'était pas extraordinaire
la nostalgie qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
la nostalgie des années 60 pour les plus
vieux d'entre nous et des années 80 ou
90 pour les plus jeunes aux personnes
malades s'agit bien sûr mais mes
frédérique la nostalgie des 60
on me fait marrer il ya quand même deux
millions de gamins qui sont allés faire
la guerre en algérie entre 56 et puis 62
et en 62 sélections qu on le voit dans
les films de l'époque où il y avait des
attentats terrible de l'ouest est la
petite-fille de malraux à et estropiés
par un attentat de l'ouest de d'imaginer
un début des années 60 super cool est
une vision totalement anachronique
c'était extrêmement dur 60000 gamins
sont morts en algérie en faisant la
guerre en algérie dans un combat qui
était qui avait l'aide la dureté que
vous savez donc moi je n'ai pas la
nostalgie de cette période où deux
millions de jeunes français étaient dans
les aurès à faire des choses contestable
et aux états unis on était proche de la
guerre civile et c'était beau
beaucoup beaucoup plus violent
qu'aujourd'hui jouissez jeunesse c'est
le titre du nouveau livre de laurent
alexandre qui vient de paraître chez
jean claude lattès
on se retrouve juste après une pause
avec nicolas michaud vous allez voir le
meilleur clip de l'année
[Musique]
nicolas michaud vous sortez votre nouvel
album amour colère sur lequel figure la
chanson parrot perroquet en anglais on
va regarder tout de suite le clip je me
trouve formidable voulait nous en dire
un mot avant qu'on le voit oui pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas c'est un clip qui a été
réalisé par mario and stare qui j'ai
collaboré sur sur cette chanson mais on
a on a conçu le clip ensemble et avec
grégoire moss aussi qui travaillent avec
moi donc une première chose voilà c'est
un clip
entre nous on l'appelait 3e titre en
seniors faith 2020 dans dans ton visage
ou non dans ta face voilà on a essayé de
résumer un petit peu les choses on n'a
pas du tout la même vision du monde et
la même lecture que que monsieur
alexandre précédemment donc vous vous le
verrez dans le clip
voilà on a essayé la dans un premier
volet d'exposer à quel point nos
dirigeants et la classe dominante nous
mener vers la catastrophe et dans un
second volet du clip on a essayé de
montrer que heureusement il y avait déjà
des gens qui qui se battaient pour
sauver ce qui peut encore l'être
voilà donc c'est à la fois une entente
ont flairé en hommage et bien on le
regarde tout de suite en tout cas un
extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nicolas michaud qu'est ce qu'elle
dit exactement cette chanson écoute les
mots du perroquet essaye de les répéter
mais à part ça et qu'est ce que vous
avez voulu dire vous c'est à dire je
pense qu'une chanson qui doit rester
relativement ouverte jeudi à l'auditeur
aussi de trouver son chemin là dedans
mais pour moi c'est une chanson sur le
sur le d'une certaine façon sur la
révolution une chanson sur l'inversion
des hiérarchies une chanson sur la
destitution des anciens pouvoir
éventuellement le remplacement par par
de nouveaux voilà je veux dire là là où
traditionnellement c'est le perroquet
qui répètent et qui ânonnent un peu
bêtement ce que ce que son propriétaire
le dit bien là cela c'est le contraire
c'est peut-être je pense et les gens qui
en général ont la parole depuis 30 ans
depuis 40 ans eh bien je pense que ces
gens il est temps qu'ils s'asseyent et
qu'ils écoutent ce que ce que ce que les
silencieux honte à dire est ce que est
ce que vous y montrer un monde violent
ou est-ce que ça n'est pas à un monde
qui joue la comédie de la violence
non je pense que le clip montre dans sa
première partie je pense le monde tel
qu'il est dans dans toute sa violence
je pense enfin cgg j'entendais récemment
dans votre émission
geoffroy de lagasnerie qui disait la non
violence ça n'existe pas chez asséché
assez d'accord avec ça je dis rien il ya
de la violence qui est là qui est qui
qui est fait sur les communautés et par
rapport à ça on peut on peut réagir de
différentes façons mais mes de la
violence et on a partout tout le temps
je veux dire pour moi l'idée que des
gens qui fuient la guerre ou qui fuient
des problèmes climatiques se retrouve en
méditerranée c'est à dire là où nous
passons nos vacances c'est à dire
vraiment au coeur de au coeur de notre
de notre univers se finit sur des canots
de sauvetage et sont plus ou moins sauvé
mais bien souvent ne sont pas secourus
de l'amour pour des raisons totalement
cynique et de façon organisée par
l'union européenne toutes ces choses là
me semble absolument inacceptable et le
summum de la violence même on va voir
une chanson plus paisible un clip plus
paisible également c'est pourtant dans
le nouvel album il mord amour colère
la chanson s'intitule harvester on la
regarde tout de suite je crois que vous
avez filmé chez vous dans l'île
vous êtes alors réfugiés exilés avec
votre femme et votre petit fils tu lille
au danemark on vous regarde on vous
écoute
[Musique]
jusqu'à mon père ma mère
je sais vous le pen c'est la crise
[Musique]
je
que de paix je le vis des clients de la
caisse
[Musique]
des sources du système
je
ce soir
son
[Musique]
là
il entend
non
[Musique]
nicolas michaud s'est il s'appelle samso
je sais pas si j'ai bien pensé il ya
quoi qu'on dise hameçon
voilà ça me ce 3000 habitants et je
crois que c'est la première ville au
monde à être arrivé à être autonome en
énergie grâce aux énergies renouvelables
c'est ça tout à fait tout à fait c'est
vrai l'islet et oui c'est ça ou
autosuffisante et au niveau énergétique
mais le tableau n'est pas comment dire
n'est pas tout blanc non plus lille a
encore énormément de l'agriculture
industrielle qui utilise du glyphosate
et autres autres intrants donc donc
voila comme partout il ya le la
transition et en est en cours il ya du
il ya du pour il ya du compte vous êtes
liégeois d'origine comme césar franck
alors quelle influence a eu liége sur
votre sur votre musique sur vos chansons
meslier j'avais beaucoup d'amis beaucoup
d'influencé là que j'ai c'est là que
j'ai grandi c'est là que j'ai fait mes
études et c'est là que j'ai commencé mon
premier groupe de rock
donc c'est pas la musique de césar
franck qui m'a beaucoup inspiré mais
mais mais de mener ce groupe de rock
quand j'avais entre entre 17 et 25 ans
m'a beaucoup ma beaucoup appris sur mon
métier on a commencé tout en bas de
l'échelle on faisait des première partie
d'un groupe de reprise des rolling
stones ce qui s'appelait bold and sticky
fingers et on a un jouet dans la région
dans les bals les mariages tout ça et on
le remplace est quand ils pouvaient pas
venir tout ça donc donc voilà c'est
comme ça qu'on a appris qu'on a que je
que j'ai appris la musique qui pourrait
dire sur eux sur le terrain je crois que
savoir qu'il s'appelait été 67 c'est ça
tout à fait tout à fait c'était mon ski
est un peu dans la nostalgie quand même
du c'était mieux avant étaient 67
oui tout à fait mais moi je moi je suis
un grand nostalgique je pense que les je
pense que l'être humain a des malgré
tout de bonnes raisons d'être
nostalgique je veux dire en deux un de
mes livres préférés ses mémoires
d'hadrien
de marguerite yourcenar je trouve que
par exemple dans ce livre est là elle
arrive à faire passer à faire sentir ce
que ça a pu être d'être un être humain
au deuxième siècle après jésus-christ et
je pense que bien sûr nous avons la
technologie pour pour nous amuser pour
nous divertir et pour nous permettre
d'apprendre plein de choses mais je
pense que les hommes du 2e siècle par
exemple après jésus-christ avait avait
d'autres avantages eh bien on va
regarder un dernier extrait c'est nos
retrouvailles parce que vous chantez
aussi en français extrait du clip là
encore une chanson tirée de ce nouvel
album
[Musique]
dans la nuit noire
j'attends vos repas théo prend part
si tu sais où je suis
ne dit rien qui va non ni noir tu te
retrouves de concret deuxièmement kva
on peut partager un cheval
[Musique]
soudain je te retrouves à
comme il vient
tête au regard des autres est devenue
rien
pour le
qui se cache
à l'arrêt
[Musique]
dans la ville sainte
les poules j'entrevois il faut l'accord
le fret sur ses doigts quand
je suis heureux
[Musique]
un clip qui sert de très bonne
introduction pour parler avec stéphane
rose d'en finir avec le couple dernier
mot nicolas michaud vous êtes en concert
vendredi prochain la marque à la
marbrerie de montreuil avec des masques
j'imagine oui oui masqué et
distanciation physique évidemment mais
mais surtout surtout bonne humeur et
envies de envie d'enfin jouer devant des
gens on se réjouit beaucoup et bien oui
c'est quand même votre spécialité au
départ vous êtes normalement voyez
habitué des longues tournées
merci nicolas je rappelle que ammour
solaire vient de sortir et que vous
serez donc au concert vendredi le 25
septembre à la marbrerie de montreuil
[Musique]
stéphane rose vous publiez en finir avec
le couple à la musardine pour vous on se
met en couple par tradition par manque
d'imagination pas parce que c'est bon
pour nous mais parce que c'est comme ça
au fond ce serait ça la raison d'être du
couple au fond c'est l'habitude où nous
a toujours dit que c'est comme ça que ça
devait se passer et la thèse exacte de
mon livre c'est que parce qu'il ya un
vocabulaire de l'amour et de la
conjugalité qui est le vocabulaire
courant que personne ne remet en
question et pour masquer un vocabulaire
prison tyltyl qui fait que à partir au
moment où on rencontre quelqu'un plutôt
que de simplement s'occuper du binôme
amoureux qu'on va former avec cette
personne tout de suite c'est une sorte
d'entité annexes qui arrive une sorte de
gros blocs gélatineux qui s'appelle le
couple et le coup qu'il arrive là avec
tout un tas de lois d'obligations qui
font chier tout le monde il faut le dire
à commencer par celle de la de la
fidélité sexuelle dans laquelle tout le
monde se dépatouille comme il peut
écoute on enlève ça c'est quand on
enlève le couple il ya juste deux
personnes et à ce moment là à mon avis
on a une relation beaucoup plus saine où
on peut composer en fonction des
spécificités des des deux parties mais
en lisant votre livre j'ai réfléchi à
quel point la publicité pour le couple
est omniprésente et notamment au cinéma
le cinéma depuis plus d'un siècle
maintenant veut absolument marier tout
le monde ça doit se finir comme ça tout
film qui est censé bien se terminer se
termine en couple oui mais il n'ya pas
que le cinéma il ya là la presse
féminine par exemple pour laquelle j'ai
un peu travaillé dont je peux parler en
connaissance de cause
ll ne parle que de ça réussir son couple
sauver son couple remettre du piment
dans son couple elle parle toujours de
son groupe et jamais de votre amoureux
par exemple donc vous avez la presse
féminine le cinéma et les comptes de
faire les comptes de fait il ya toujours
le prince charmant tout ça est la
religion elle elle veut
on soit en couple surtout pour que la
semence ne s'épanche pas hors du vase et
qu'on fasse des enfants le politique il
veut des cellules familiales qui vont
fabriquer des petits consommateurs et je
peux vous dire que quand on est ni pacsé
ni mariés comme moi on paye beaucoup
plus d'impôts donc on n'est plus unique
et vous avez tout le monde en fait
le politique le religieux la culture
populaire qui nous impose ce coûte donc
personne ne veut et on le subit tous
arrêtés plus personne n'en veut d'autant
plus que vous l'avez fait remarquer tout
notre vin cabu l'air en dit long sur la
prison en fait qu'est le couple dès
l'instant on parle d'amour on parle
d'attachement on dit qu'on est casé on
dit qu'on est mct et ça en dit long
ça en dit long sur l'idée même que l'on
se fait du couple le mot maquée par
exemple moi je le trouve formidable
parce que il ya de fait plein de gens
disent oh je suis mac et mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire makheia 2 il ya deux
acceptions à ce terme soit ça veut dire
je suis mangé
donc je suis en train de me faire
digérer et je serai bientôt chier pardon
d'être vulgaire mais c'est çà et là
deuxième acception du ter c'est je suis
mac et j'ai un maquereau c'est à dire
voilà je suis prise en main jeu et je
vais faire rentrer de l'argent par les
moyens de vous savez et ça ça ne fait
pas envie
si vous voulez moi ça ne me fait pas
envie et je comprends pas pour 10 de son
plein gré je suis mac et où je suis casé
casey c'est pareil un casey c'est la
case à la maison donc mon amour en fait
c'est les murs du foyer et on ne peut
pas en sortir
vous avez aussi l'enterrement de vie de
garçon l'enterrement de vie de jeune
fille
moi si je trouve ça fascinant ce truc
avant de se marier un sens terre c'est à
dire qu'on enterre la liberté qu'on
avait et ensuite qu'est ce qu'on fait on
va poser un cadenas d'amour un jeu tous
les gens qui habitent paris ont visité
paris connaît ça vous avez des ponts
entier qui sont recouverts de cadenas
sens est censée symboliser de l'amour
éternel mais qu'est ce qui symbolise le
plus la captivité qu'un cadenas
je pose la question à l'eau salée pas
strictement parisien c'est absolument
dans toutes les villes d'europe et je
crois que l'origine ça vienne serbie
d'ailleurs le concert de klaxons au
moment du mariage
c'est vrai que ça aussi c'est une vie
ricou tubes bien plus ancienne que
l'enterrement de la vie de garçon qui
nous vient des états unis je crois ou la
saint valentin c'est pareil mais le
concert de klaxons j'ai toujours entendu
dire ça qu'est ce que vous entendez là
dedans vous ben les gens nous disent que
c'est la fête mais pas du tout parce que
on les connaît pas les gens qui
klaxonnent ils font chier objectivement
c'est tous les jours c'est c'est
toujours le samedi et le dimanche à
l'heure de la sieste qui viennent nous
réveiller donc pourquoi ils viennent me
réveiller c'est à dire qu'ils veulent me
faire savoir qu'ils sont en train se
marier mais pourquoi me le faire savoir
parce que à mon avis renonce à quelque
chose et ils veulent ils voudraient que
moi j'y renonce il voudrait que tout le
monde y renonce ils disent une voilà je
suis marié maintenant vous allez tous
vous mariez yassa d'une part d'ailleurs
c'est un truc intrusif et liberticide et
l'autre chose c'est c'est enfin je suis
sortie de l'infamie du célibat parce que
le célibat
la liberté c'est quelque chose de sale
c'est quelque chose d'inconvenant donc à
partir du moment où enfin on est guéri
de cette vilaine maladie on peut
klaxonner et on peut dire à tout le
monde voilà ça y est je suis guéri je
suis socialement acceptable je suis casé
mcee et donc ou rouge et roger enfin une
relation sérieuse d'assister les
chaussures très terme la relation
sérieuse
5 ça fait pas rêver hein quand on le dit
comme ça mais ton mandat est très fier
tout le monde mais tout le monde le
revendique vous allez sur les applis et
les sites de rencontre et le nombre de
gens qui disent j'ai plus le temps de
m'amuser je cherche du sérieux cherche
relation sérieuse uniquement mais je
trouve le monde moi tellement déjà
sérieux tellement chiant tellement plein
de contraintes que l'amour qui est quand
même le lieu où on boit des coups on
baise et on rigole
il faut surtout pas l'associer à du
sérieux fins et le lad le dernier espace
de nos vies oui il faut pas de sérieux
donc je ne comprends pas mais en même
temps les l'opposé c'est faire n'importe
quoi
avant d'engager relation sérieuse je
faisais n'importe quoi
passionnément puisqu'on a enregistré que
la norme c'est d'avoir une relation
sérieuse quand on papillonne quand on
expérimente ses fantasmes
quand on rencontre des gens hors du
cadre de la conjugalité ont 10 h fait
n'importe quoi j'étais célibataire à
l'époque je faisais n'importe quoi je
ramenais une femme dont
sommes maintenant tu faisais pas
n'importe quoi en fait tu vivais en
corrélation avec tes fantasmes
parce que c'est ça dont tu avais besoin
à ce moment de ta vie et à partir du
moment où tu aime le sexe que tu aimes
baiser que tu aimes faire des rencontres
si tu renonces à ça c'est que tu
renonces à toi même et donc c'est que le
couple n'était pas une option pour toi
donc tu oses l inverse de n'importe quoi
pour pas que le couple sarah t et ils
s'arrêtent souvent les couples les
statistiques nous le prouve tous les
jours on vit ça comme un échec et et on
veut recommencer à zéro mais recommencer
pareil c'est à dire que ça il remet
jamais en question le couple lui-même
c'est c'était juste celui là qui était
un échec et ça aussi ça vous choque un
oui ça me choque parce que derrière tout
ça il ya une autre expression qui va
avec ça c'est faire sa vie et refaire sa
vie il faut faire sa vie comme si notre
vie n'était pas déjà fait à part du
moment où on est nous travaillons payent
des impôts on a suffisamment de truction
à gérer non il faut encore faire sa vie
quand on est en couple et la refaire
parce que si la cie l'histoire s'arrête
la relation est un échec
donc ça veut dire que quoi qu'on fasse
il ya que la conjugalité qui l état
acceptable de la relation amoureuse mais
entre quand on a 20 ans quand on a 40
ans quand on a 60 ans on n'a pas les
mêmes aspirations et donc on ne
recherche pas les mêmes partenaires à 20
ans néo romantique on veut peut-être une
belle histoire ou alors on veut pas du
tout se faire chier voilà à 40 ans veut
autre chose on a déjà ses gosses on veut
des relations un peu plus distante donc
en fonction de l'âge les partenaires
changent donc arrêter une relation pour
en commencer une autre qui nous
ressemblent plus celle inverse d'un
échec c'est une réussite
il faudrait pas dire ma relation est un
échec c'est ma relation s'arrête parce
qu'on a tous les deux fait notre chemin
dans cette relation et on veut autre
chose maintenant j'ai d'autres ambitions
donc je vais commencer une autre une
autre relation et merci la rupture pour
cette opportunité alors la fidélité
sexuelle c'est vrai que c'est le centre
de de tous les problèmes qui se posent
dans le couple pas tous d'ailleurs parce
qu'il faut aussi les les
incompatibilités d'humeur les égoïsmes
etc etc
enfin la fidélité sexuelle c'est vrai
que ça vous travail
je pense que ce travail tout le monde et
ses skis
c'est ce qui valide le plus l'at elle la
thèse de mon livre parce que moi je
connais personne dans tous les amis que
je connais j'ai des gens près normaux
qui est qu'il n'ait pas été infidèle un
moment où pour lequel le l'idée de
passer
l'ampl l'intégralité de sa vie avec le
même corps n'est pas un problème donc
ébats chacun bricole un peu comme il
peut soit on admet que son par son
partenaire va avoir d'autres relations
ont la nette passe tacitement
mais dans ce cas-là bon bah on n'est pas
obligé de le dire mais la fidélité était
quand même un problème à gérer
soit on ne le supporte pas et ça peut au
casino occasionné la fin de l'histoire
donc l'infidélité est un problème soit
tout le monde se fait fait des coups en
douce et c'était un problème soit on va
dans un club libertin parce qu'on a trop
besoin de découvrir d'autres corps mais
ça n'en reste pas moins un problème à
régler
alors que si d'emblée on arrive à dire
voilà on est amoureux on fait une
relation mais c'est difficile il ya de
la jalousie à gérer mais on n'est pas
fidèle on ne se promet pas ce truc
eh bien à mon avis la relation est
beaucoup plus solide et mais comment au
fond le couple c'est avant tout du sexe
l'amour c'est du sexe la passion ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la passion
amoureuse c'est du sexe
autrefois les mariages d'amour ne
reposait pas du tout sûr sur cette
nécessité d'une vie sexuelle richer et
variées
donc comment organiser sa vie sexuelle
sans passé sans s'enfermer dans le
couple au fond c'est ça le problème
puisque vous avez l'air de dire que tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire que le
couple s'est pas la solution
et au fond on en serait tous plus ou
moins conscient sans vouloir se l'avouer
comment faire autrement on va pas quand
même région le finder
ça va pas quand même et grinder qui va
tout régler puis si jamais il se
prétendre si jamais les spétes en lave
on est mort moi ce que je suggère c'est
que quand on tombe amoureux de quelqu'un
on lui dise voilà tout et moins on ne
fait pas un couple on est exactement
comme deux amis sauf qu'en plus on baise
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec des amis on
parle on boit des coups on refait le
monde on se promène on part en vacances
bah nous ça va être pareil et va y avoir
de la sexuelle sexualité en plus mais un
ami je vais jamais l'emmerdé parce que
si parce que ça parce qu'il m'a pas
appelé parce que il n'ya pas
d'obligation avec les amis ni avec les
parents
minier dans une relation professionnelle
il ya qu'avec le couple ou non de cette
espèce d'entité magique qui s'appelle le
couple on s'impose une série
d'obligations si on définit toutes les
obligations du couple et qu'on s'en
débarrasse
on dit voilà il ya deux amis qui baise
c'est une sorte d'amitié sexuelle et à
mon avis là les choses deviennent plus
faciles à gérer
oui pas facile de ma vous rencontrez ava
gardner vous avez pas envie d'être
copain avec ava gardner voyez vous
voulez que j'ai de la fièvre qui est de
la passion qui est très sûr qu'on s'aime
on vous passera outre on peut avoir de
la passion sans forcément mais justement
s'il ya de la passion
pourquoi s'emmerder avec la prison du
couple et toutes ses obligations
contraignantes dont on sait très bien
soit dit en passant que elle tue la
passion
1 c'est le fameux roman de bic bb
l'amour dure 3 ans et une formule mais
on est tous d'accord
le désir sexuel il ya un moment ça
s'arrête faut arrêter de se mentir on
peut le faire prolonger en achetant
trois sextoys un peu de lingerie sexy en
allant se délurée en club échangiste
mais il ya un moment ça va s'arrêter
donc la passion bah si on veut la porter
il faut enlever enlever le groupe et
admettre et c'est là c'est là aussi
qu'on enlève le couple qu' il ya un
moment elle s'arrête et qu'on passe à
autre chose et que l'histoire était
borné dans le temps ce qui renvoie à la
notion d'engagement qui est pareil c'est
le premier commandement du couple un
l'engagement j'ai plein de copines qui
disent oh les mecs aujourd'hui ils
veulent pas s'engager mais prends ça
comme une opportunité il veut pas
s'engager ça veut dire qu'il va vivre le
truc au jour le jour
éval vivre vraiment alors que s'engage
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire promettre un avenir qu'on ne pourra
pas garantir et de fait je rappelle ce
sont les statistiques de l'insee qu'un
mariage sur deux pas sur cinq ans tout
sur son un mariage sur deux se solde par
un divorce donc s'engager ça veut dire
aujourd'hui je m'engage avec toi mais tu
as 50 % de chances que ça et dans le mur
donc autant de passes engagé oui surtout
que le stade mots qui nous rappelle
aussi l'armée c'est à dire est une
institution dans laquelle quand on
rentre on abolit toute liberté
effectivement c'est pas forcément
folichon
merci stéphane rose en finir avec le
couple ça vient d'eux
paraître elle est musardine et les
statistiques nous dirons plus tard si
vous avez triomphé ou pas de cette
vénérable institution
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez-vous
au prochain numéro
[Musique]